evening all we've just seen an
absolutely magnificent game which we're
not going to tell you the result of it
was between aronian and boot Shane so
okay I'm with my good friend Chris and I
Chris yeah hi so should we take it from
White's point of view or black point of
view would you reckon yeah let's just
keep it that way I think we never
switched sides here I never will switch
the board and did I'm not showing my
tell something about the games result
yes there was no implication so by what
I've just said about the cameras all so
so so if we okay aronian plain white
played them be four yeah and just just
quickly um it's um it's another game
from the Sun tal memorial tournament we
in round three now mmm and if you look
at the standings Aronian is on +1 so he
won one game and drew yesterday so is in
quite good position tournament but beg
Shane lost the first two games yeah and
he's already if you look looking just to
the just on paper is quite an outside
and this tournament it's very strong
obviously but it's not quite quite up
there so there might be the idea that
their own Ian thought okay I need to win
this game yes and it it really shows and
in the opening here and lot that they
are the outset but quite quickly we see
that we've got an uncle compromising fry
dead so it starts awesome relatively
yeah conventionally with their with the
sloth defense so now I have free
absolutely don't Slav yep and I've seen
Luca shame beats like mackerel Kings
engine at London classic actually
because he plays in London classic HD
and that's been really amazing to watch
and he also beat Coulson as well in long
classic white side of an English opening
so he has beaten
some great players from the storm
already in the classic yeah sure mean
right now he managed to get his raging
22 to a level which much more with Lexus
his to true playing strength I guess
he's on 27 a little bit 2703 or
something what do we have here to 700
six or whatever you so it's his like top
40 or so in the world which may be quite
quite Fitz's his true strength it was
just a couple of years ago on 26 20 or
30 or something and I think this didn't
really fit with the visibility's of
course he's he's no professional player
you need to take this into account he's
got regular day job and just place those
tournaments um in his free time so to
say the global sizes whoa whoa babe me
in his funky yeah I think it's in the
best banking so um he's not really a
full-time professional okay so but we
got this a 6-line I'm not quite sure if
you played this before often even I
didn't look that up bunch of course it's
a very um common opening nowadays um
what Bishop g5 really is a huge surprise
here from uronian this is so quite an um
uncommon move nowadays when this
variation sort of became popular which
is the early 90s mid-nineties this
Bishop g5 was one of the first moves
that white ride which of course it's a
move it some which make them quite some
sense at the outset because it's a usual
move against a six against e6 also so it
makes a normal impressed to just develop
the bishop yeah actually what McShane
now played he took on C formed it's a
sideline here DC voices as rather
unusual yeah the normal way to play he
is 94 which is most often played and
this is of course the huge difference
six that you have this this somewhat we
had not jump in and this actually forces
why to Lou to move again with this
bishop or play age for which is also
liked once in a while but usually it
continues like this just to to show this
brief and this is a pure pawn sacrifice
for for white rule and it's actually
questionable if this is enough for one
so it's quite quite surprising that
aronian went for this um okay he
obviously had said some idea in mind
it's not bad for wide or anything but
it's not the kind of line worldwide
recently um I to ride phone advantage so
Bishop g5 was quite surprising yeah um
but that makes me actually didn't play
94 took on c4 it's just all so um no
move um yeah and now a form trying to
yeah make it make it more difficult for
like two baby five yes yeah but now I've
got h6 yes actually I've just been
recently as that pin video by tomorrow i
looked at recently he talked about
Bishop g5 as sometimes not useful pin
here it's not even a pen yet but his
argument was sometimes the bishop can be
a subject to tempo gain and and put on
where where it was on sort of both
diagonals is now just on one diagonal of
hits if it's kick to h4 I know it's all
theory but the this this 86 and g5 could
be really useful to black I know there's
tons of theory on this but as a sort of
idea of Bishop g5 generally sometimes
not being effective for potential pin
yeah yeah yeah that's true I mean here
aged 6 s just just gains a move because
white why doesn't want to take on f6
anyway which would be just anti
positional
so plates plates bishop age for ya and
now a surprising move from from black
here on b5 and this position is actually
a pretty rare position I looked it up in
in my database and there are only iphone
I found only four games on this position
and magazine it's not the icing we've
got so much theory and this looks like a
beautiful idea coming up absolutely
stunning idea coming up I'm blue yeah
okay yeah it's not not so unbelievable I
mean one of the games is actually give
mine oh yeah i played this as black um a
couple of years ago you played this idea
yeah sure sure it's pretty well no one
actually if you know this line it's
nothing special but the thing is i had
prepared this as well as black against
the player where I knew that you would
play Bishop g5 so this was my
preparation just sort of surprise him of
course 94 is fine and so on five but I
thought this was a nice idea um but in
this game my opponent didn't didn't play
as Aronian played and I think what he
played is true was just better actually
I mean he's was only 2300 rated and
compared to the 2800 of live one here
but my opponent just played he formed
this position all right but what I did I
reacted very very badly so this was a
terrible game that hit that late I'm not
quite sure what's what's correct I know
what I would have played it was what was
terrible but i'm not sure what Sherwood
was sorcery was right i think i played
if i remember correctly I played some
stuff like this year right and this was
just terrible oh you know I mean just
looking at the development I I really
got I'd really didn't get my pieces and
go into play at all in this game so I
think this was a bad idea yeah um okay
but we don't want to look at my game
it's just just funny that this came up
so some people go about a bit surprised
about the oldest but well I had prepared
this years ago so I knew that
what the one was doing now is is very
rare risk him and okay we see what
what's coming up yeah so okay aight
aight spain and of course there's a pin
on the iphone and it looks as though it
has black actually blundered here
because you know why not try and exploit
this pin hey and good okay but i love
this type of sacrifice i think this is
must be one of my favorite types of
sacrifice where you thought you seemed
really casual and chilled out in doing
the sacrifice and then you get a massive
initiative soon after so much things be
fun yeah so it's very very interesting
and very young yeah it's very rare to
see this kind of stuff it sometime
sevens and in cellular variations of the
Slav but yeah here so it's it's very
very risky to play for white I mean it's
okay the thing is back and just take
here yeah white grab the rook and Bishop
d7 winning a temple here so positional
exchange tanks so basically this bishops
kind of been shot down from this
diagonal and also protecting this
diagonal it's no on h4 this is yes it's
brilliant and controllably Falls
brilliant this this c 6 is going to be
really dangerous soon for the Bishop b4
check yeah this also shows the merit of
the sage six sons here without this
movement would be just one sincere know
if if you wouldn't have played h6 and
Bishop age form because lesser let's at
once two moves wide to be treated the
rock you know it's got no no better
square here and ya know black want a
temple here with the g5 and then played
e6 actually it's also possible um it's
not sure that this is good but it also
would be possible to play you five even
blimey which is the the a brutal way to
to buy I'm not sure that it's better or
anything but just to point out it it's
possible to do this smooth you have
you've got this immediate threat here
you should be full before and so wyd so
sorry only five white would still play
something like this here and then check
we get get stuff like this is quite
similar to the game only after c5 move
it's questionable if this is better
really i think maybe what McShane did
was better but technically possible on
this move is for sure okay so he just
played e6 p.m. and this is the whole
point of this operation um yeah the shot
of bishop e ng three doesn't help in
defending this diagonal here yeah blacks
ship coming to before yeah it's just a
super annoying motive yes it's just
amazing how you know if white tries to
like fend off it'll backfire say Queen
d2 us play 94 anyway so here you just
take your paper should be fortunate
winning the rook check oh so nothing
really works is it i means against this
check it's uncomfortable to stop this
chair it's it's really really difficult
so he went III here yeah I mean what
what good what else could you try if you
say let's say move like Quincy to just
just briefly I can also check here and
yeah then you need to play this ugly
move which you didn't didn't want to I
mean this is not playable for white this
is even worth looking at a man to be
Bishop ever in Queen D for my maybe
maybe yeah this is sort of if nothing
else you can play this but you don't
want to give up this Bishop that easily
because you can also just harass the
Queen here whoops with Bishop a fool if
ya all kinds of all kinds of stuff are
good here and it's actually that I think
the most most difficult in this kind of
position for black is to choose from so
many nice looking possibilities so I
think in comparison what would Aronian
played is certainly better so III you
should before check and kinky too and
you know what's what really amazes me
about this year is look at the times I
mean McShane as spent an hour about
our already years oh he may be wakely
remembered this idea and then just
played this I'm just speculating here
but no it's not a piece of preparation
so he sort of suddenly knew this idea i
guess and came up with us at the board
but aronian obviously went into this
completely yam willingly oh it's not an
accident or something that he is playing
instantly and I don't know I mean you
need to be very very brave to go into
this position sort of voluntarily right
I guess he might think well he's going
to shut down the bishop if he moves the
night and plays a free and then put the
king maybe later on King f2 they left
later yeah amazing a liquid main idea
was that he's playing a guy who who lost
his first two games and was also always
spending I mean huge amounts of time and
then maybe you just thought okay I get
him into some huge time trouble and
maybe the position is somewhat shaky but
I don't know he won't be able to to play
this correctly with so little time i'm
not sure but there is a thirty-second
increments yeah there is okay but he
won't overstep the time or something but
i mean i don't know i mean my honest
opinion to play this is just crazy
really really the exchange of you don't
let me tell completely bonkers you
ladies really no it's just my opinion i
mean if you just place a normal kind of
pressing game he okay my draw you might
win but you never had this is just ugly
it don't get like oh you know a club
game where whites sort of rye wheat
flour and he doesn't like castle it's
overly clever in a different perception
of this game it could have been a club
game you can it looks it looks if you
first look at it you think oh my god
what do I do here then is is an exchange
our behalf
so like sacrifice something to get this
position yeah okay it's um I don't know
maybe a matter of good nerves or
anything but I would never play this but
ok it's um I don't know I just hated
this kind of South way you you're moving
around with your king in the opening and
you don't have your pieces playing and
so on yeah it's um I mean it's difficult
yeah maybe it's it's still so equal or
anything but I think it's quite clear
that like has very very nice
compensation so yeah okay but let's get
only I think what McShane played was
service very nice IAM you won't donate
seasick poop so sorry 966 yeah yeah 96
and i think this is a good move I mean
you also could maybe half the idea like
97 be six or anything but this is just
much stronger yeah it's making use of
the most aggressive porn isn't it
because he's got an idea now potentially
of night a five to be free so you yeah
aggressive hook and if he gets that
night then this rook is kind of made
more tactically vulnerable hasn't got
too many squares when it was attacked
yeah and this is very nice to get the
night of beauty which is an excellently
a place there it's a very aggressive
square in fact if you look at this I
fall black controls most of the squares
on the iphone here yeah whites whites
rooks are both a joke the h1 rook will
take ages to get into the game so and
the a1 will come soon we'll only have
will have 0 square so this night comes
here it's another square on the iphone
totally fell domination in fact that all
my things it's really America what what
what wide was thinking when he got into
this okay but whatever yeah okay he
played 91 now hmm which which which
looks quite logical because there's a
there's nine see two to maybe be going
and then there's b this.f Freed's which
can improve the king and then h4 and so
there's a few implication
and maybe even this Bishop coming later
so it looks as though you know okay
maybe can white untangle or not this
position yeah okay I'm one thing I did a
brief analysis before he started the
video i want to show just quickly one in
one line that I that I looked at this
was 95 which also I thought made some
sense to maybe get rid of the night here
in a way and then play play this this f3
king f2 stuff yeah um and but black of
course doesn't it doesn't take he plays
95 anyway I'm going to be three and just
a quick quick line here that I looked at
let's say f3 here Matt to be three of
rocker saying so does it have a good
square let's go to a two and then nine
to d5 and yeah this is very dangerous
wide just one sample sample line here
which looks quite logical this should be
one maneuver that he also mentioned to
get rid of the bishop let's see here
here and now it's already yeah I time to
strike yes I think this there's a slight
weakness of that last move I'm not
protecting Devo yeah I think this is
more like a weakness of the whole
position alright so okay yeah she takes
can you too yes it's yeah okay black can
just take only five was a good position
but if you give this to computer for a
couple of seconds yeah it will come up
even with castling with the idea playing
rook da don so yea it's going on the
default yeah and this actually is
already completely winning for black hmm
it's not even playable or anything is
just winning let's say this this here
this was a sample line and resins you
three made coming I mean this whole
position is just ridiculously yes this
guy is not really just contributing
but it's just like okay place the pieces
absolutely randomly where they don't
make any sense this is position so okay
it's just it just shows some a line of
attack for black he's just a rope down
here but it's just made yeah so okay
this was some briefly looking at at 95
so I'm 91 okay it's an idea yeah and now
as some as mentioned oops can just as
this one black gum goes to be three with
us night hmm now what is the exchange up
so I think we look at a few options
maybe if there's an option to sack the
exchange but coming up but Bishop f5
okay he's creating another pen which
might be annoying um potentially what so
what in this position is it a bishop 'if
I've will do anything else or is it just
is it one of the bat moves considering
yeah I mean what-what shot should wide
play I mean it makes sense in a way it's
a versus age for idea so yeah I mean
it's not looking completely completely
lost so anything quite so strong trying
to to get some play going and also with
this f3m kind of maneuver maybe improve
his King so on I think this should be
fine so black cathode know yeah anyone
else you need to get this night on move
and now H form g4 maybe this idea
attracted Aronian to this position I'm
not sure so night see to be a very very
logical Mandy since night didn't have
any square go to f3 or d3 or whatever so
he gains his temper here yeah legs
dropping back yeah and now funny move
king he won because actually actually
there was also a fret of bishop f6 some
rope a five so he's protecting that
against bishop f6 yeah right it's a
bishop d6 was played then then then
Bishop f6 would win that yeah
d 6 I mean just just a blunder oops wait
yeah yeah this was smoking so it so both
of us win apiece so he needed to go I
think this was all really um gab quite
logical I mean what would you call
logical in such a position but yeah look
at the time spike Shane down to 20
minutes and aronian saw with more than
an hour on the clock so yeah it's so on
seemed like Eve didn't fall too
uncomfortable yeah okay and now it's
difficult he came up with King e1 maybe
you can also argue for for every year
but okay this makes sense in a way
because it threatens Bishop f6 and Queen
chief or so oh yes yes I immediately um
yeah threatened something yes yeah I
think he he 193 anyway hmm the checking
are checking here so that's interesting
um ok so if white goes ahead with what
did he play he didn't play Bishop F sexy
paper ok too if he goes ahead with
Bishop f6 this would be a disaster i
guess i'm not sure i'm not sure this is
so bad i didn't download let us move
strangely enough forgot about this i
guess but it makes sense that's a bishop
takes here you take CM jack this kind of
stuff yeah no no you need to somehow
move your oak and the thing is i mean
you maybe you would like to go here
check what this is unfortunately made
next move that's brutal brutal oh yeah
this is already a sudden sudden death
situation yeah so I guess okay let's see
here so needs to go here maybe you know
and yeah what what now I black asses for
Nia Scott's this move I mean this is
just this refusal isn't a potentially
together
I don't thing is I just hate this
position I mean why does what is why
doing here this-this-this pieces are all
jokes these pieces are refusing to
coordinate with each other yeah you
cannot Castle his move this King already
a couple of times it looks really bad I
think white white is just it's just
terrible here mmm I don't see a movie
even what what should my play here I
mean if you get to take on default you
will just completely walk over white
yeah because the yeah this sense will
foul crashing through once this d4 looks
pretty good as well these javax hopeless
I mean these to us this is bad bad news
okay so that explains maybe why Bishop
f6 is not that tempting so plays rook a2
we go into the game so rook a2 and now
we see h5 just locking up against bishop
f6 now yeah yeah it's quite this is
quite a weird position there with h5
energy for sort of thrown in here but
okay what should why do that yes you
really cannot play any normal moves
anymore so I mean the White has moved to
sting twice already so if you wouldn't
you might think okay maybe there should
be two castles so I've like this but
it's not possible in one yeah and it's
really difficult to suggest moves here
now in most aronian games his pool
structure was quite good but what we're
about to see is is going to another
island at the moment there's two porn
islands for why and to sort of great
generate some counter play he's going to
splinter his own porn structure now he's
going to play soon for everybody face
Bishop e2 first but um okay so Bishop e2
very interesting offering g2 here trying
to get some counter play now I mean I'm
not quite sure maybe I'm seeing all this
to to negatively but I think he his main
idea was not to play quickly and get him
into you
I'm trouble so that he might screw up in
time trouble this position I mean the
position itself is just terrible all
right for white so I don't know maybe
I'm too pessimistic here but um I think
if he would now think 30 minutes he
won't come up with a good move anyway
and it would just help McShane to sort
of work out how to progress him right I
mean this at least it sets a little trap
here he played um should be six here
yeah if you did please it doesn't need
speed materialistic here and we'll just
give white play wouldn't it rook g1 then
how are you might be there it yeah the
thing is it's not just play Bishop g4 is
smiting I'm not made but it's it's it's
bad damn oh yeah because we got h5
coming I haven't reached yet we got um
it's not that hot is it so Bishop g6
there's h5 and the other things this
even wince instantly for white if King
here yeah just almost this too much yeah
it's this too much and now White's king
is our odds to save I can just making
two of them okay not King it too because
of night see one but I mean black has no
attack yeah this is too much yeah i mean
what black or do we could in this
position I maybe do some retreat ians to
not lose immediately but obviously this
is not what Blair James oh no he's
activated the rook the route doesn't
need to do anything leave the room
asleep both rooks need to be left to
sleep then I'm up what are you doing it
necessary to to take an turn TV played
this very nicely played Bishop 26 year
which is sort of i mean even in this
very messy looking position yeah it's
still common common logic here to
exchange whites only active piece which
is a bishop mmm and you see the position
really collapses quickly i'm after the
bishop physics is exchanged um so um
yeah what would shoot what should white
do now like f3 here o0 do I just
couldn't believe this game now every 00
every looks are something's gone really
badly wrong for y if his play
just always the structure is getting
told the bits yeah yeah 11 funny line
here what would what I looked at and
when I looked at via drew k7 trying to
activate him because so I saw a thing
okay I'm black doesn't want to take on
g2 yeah because it just can help it only
can help white in it so maybe this move
is not the two desirable so maybe let's
let's go here just centralized this and
now a funny line which is necessarily
force but I just want to want to show it
because it's quite quite nice let's see
here to protect you to finally and we
get into getting some sort of
coordination going and say e 5 and so
what should why do now um if for
instance he takes him like just
recaptures and this is just a terrible
position to play what should what should
why do now you just improved your pieces
further let's say 94 route d8 and let
yourself as an attack this piece is just
not playing yeah no plans early yeah and
an even funnier line here which is so
absolutely cool so like black playing e5
let's say white rice this move here
which looks clever at first sight
because the night doesn't have any
squares hmm yeah you sort of think okay
I need to exchange on a one but like
like is this nice move and this wins
outright even or good please freak me
out yeah totally it's totally over d3
and look at look at those pieces since
it's nice it's funny it's funny um yeah
and our black black and black and simply
improve his position yeah just stuff
like this year you can just play play
just like nothing's nothing specialist
is always happening and this yes it just
it just is just a funny line that then I
cake came up with and why this complete
each rider to yeah yeah I mean black has
just a very very strong attack and it's
a it's just basically 44 just in
exchange I'm you look so I ok Roque
seven didn't didn't really young it's an
improvement isn't so well he went deaf
three I think it's sort of
understandable to try to open up the
Kings side where maybe you get a little
bit of something against the king it
didn't really materialize but no it's
understandable that you wanted to
complicate matters further sometimes you
simply cannot be resourceful if you've
been if all your pieces are disconnected
with each other it's the yellow to be
resource mean you only can't find
resources yeah where there are me if
it's if it's just I mean but I think
this is quite neat if this poem goes
like this we're gonna have a weekend
diagonal I think that's quite a neat
aspect of this position coming yeah this
comes up quickly he went the night 35 I
wondered why it didn't take money five
but I think it's mostly a GAD sort of
other move order it doesn't change so
much because why took on g4 now too yeah
get a bit of something on the king and
now it takes on takes on e5 yeah
and youthful yeah I guess this Queen
into position yeah and I mean you always
need to think okay black like a
sacrifice in exchange here but what is
this rook to Anglia I mean the ride on
on b3 is just so much stronger you know
it controls the rook here it's got
default on the control it's just hidden
this wide invasively mean White's Queen
has only one square where it could go to
and this is the great square be one so
it's not amazing you can get such a high
rating and get a position like this
still it's it's I mean yes if I don't
know I I mean it's not a matter of
playing strength or anything he just had
a completely wrong idea and in the
preparation or whatever I'm not sure or
maybe him I mean no idea maybe it is
Betty em somehow prepared this let's say
to move forward in 15 and then someone
had had an idea which simply was not
working and the ball I mean it's
possible it's hard to tell hmm it's
really have to tell I mean now you look
at it I think oh my god itself it's
horrible but he certainly had some idea
when he when he went for this yeah yeah
no idea okay but let's let's continue
here I think I mean I obviously when i
did this brief Priam analysis here i
used i use the dini engine to to check
the technical lines because i didn't
have the time to look at this myself for
three hours and and for a while it
already gave this position has clearly
data for back yeah it with the whole
exchange down i mean it is also quite
quite interesting i mean this kind of
position if you give this to d need
already tells you that black has an
advantage here you know in the engines
are so strong now that they really see
this kind of compensation and a cup I
mean this is all already outright
winning more like mmm I mean it's it's
really beyond beyond saving the only
hope here for wide was the clock times
you know i mean the rope still had lots
of time left and McShane down to seven
minutes I think when I was so I was
funny on a cycle chest bomb and I think
Bishop every was given this one of the
stronger moves anyway in the
circumstances to play Bishop f-free here
because they have a real engine running
when you're when you're watching yeah
but I'll year the advantages for black
really it's just so it's ugly and I
forgot to show 11 line actually oh maybe
maybe I should I should I should do this
briefly because it's it makes quite some
senses idea if white would have taken
here yeah just just proven that King f2
which was actually I think line that I
thought one when i watch the game live
and because this looks I don't know it's
like ordination for Wyatt done this King
on f2 you know cut some sensitive
squares and maybe you even can get your
routine to play at some point um yeah
black can actually just play a fire fuu
yeah just just um yeah just I mean no
need to protect the spawn here yeah what
can take you can just take with the pawn
and get a huge attack on the fo and what
what's white supposed to do now I mean
you can't sleep so I give my rookie won
this Queen comin down saybrook e1 yeah
this year you know it's pretty miserable
and you're gonna get mater I the Kings
get mated with jay king queen age 10 my
miserable as good i think it's it's
outright loser I mean I'm touch them if
you give why I me check yes and I mean
what what what what's the idea to
prevent this it's hot seat I mean let's
say this let's say I don't know what
what what you fat move should-should why
try here may be back here and then this
kind of stuff it's always fun to have
the king as it's all get ready this is a
good
figure the memory of towel isn't it
because because channel had kings like
this than me the opponent's Kings
getting slaughtered like this check me
okay yeah so it's just so it's just a
fun of tech here do you think this this
games the good good memory of towel so
far the best memory of town this game so
far yeah it's a it's a very nice
jiggling dis of course yeah okay oh this
didn't this wouldn't def helps really so
ok I'm back to this queen bee sixth
position so he went on Bishop Jeff three
hmm in fact sorry for islands would you
count these as two different islands
technically i saw one content recently
treat them as if you have pawns like
this there are actually two different
islands so to free maybe four five six i
don't know i don't count islands if i
get made it it's one for me not to get
mated i would count I mean technically
an endgame yeah this or maybe two
islands I don't know I don't count
really in the game I'm just looking at
the structure and I don't know the
weaknesses you know i really i really
really i rarely count really i just look
at the the position s as a whole how it
looks to me yeah so um okay but here
it's just it's more it's more yeah a
bloodthirsty affair he just took only
three here yeah and broke through I mean
we could maybe look at other moves could
could white I mean white cannot even
protect you three year this is just I
would love brook okay free yeah yeah
you're right alright then route the
eight I actually have a look at this
okay and what now you know I suppose
there's a fair of say well multiple
France yeah okay let's say let's see
here and then you've got this nice move
ah will you I do a queen g1 yeah we've
got check space and weight us here oh
wow and now this one here oh that night
is very very useful isn't it
it's it's this is just just great here
what I'm so miserable and I mean you
cannot really you cannot cover have to
when you can do this desperado movement
then next move its Queen after Jack made
yeah it's a HS terrible so this wouldn't
have helped either so he went with this
you should be a 3 after which leg could
just take him mmm and he's down to five
minutes but okay five minutes is it's
not a lot of time but I mean we playing
five-minute games all the time so yeah
you sometimes even managed to win a one
position but to get to move 40 he'll get
the recharger time move 40 so it's 15
moves but it's 30 second increment /
move I also also right young I mean even
if you would have just five minutes
without any increment I think he would
have firm managed okay so wyd needs to
take what else is there and now the
Queen comes in now we can gain some time
in the clock with a few checks without
without breaching the free fold
repetition rule will that without
invoking that yes ya think this was a
very a professional teacher yeah to just
check it here yeah and then showing mama
yeah and now with the bishop f3 to
continue our playful win here yeah and
what I cannot play Queen sites because
of night take see one attacking the rook
yeah that is funny this witness just an
unlucky little it moves in this check on
d freeze well yeah yeah you're just yeah
it's terrible so okay widen its to needs
to take can't then you can check give a
couple of checks again check very useful
yeah so I now you still have 526 moves
to go yeah so this was very nicely done
and some people thought that he might
bottle out for a draw but it would be
such a waste and tragedy if he just did
a draw by repetition just because his
opponents aronian he you know he shows
no fear that's brilliant and he doesn't
want to be the torment bunny to be
beaten up by everyone because once they
sense weakness in this kind of torment
though
go for him afternoon I yeah I mean that
was actually what uronian was trying
here in this game mmm this was the kind
of game where you and sort of risk a lot
as white and trying to win against a
person who you might think isn't in his
best form was already a bit of I don't
know in a bed moral because he lost two
games already or whatever yeah in one
game he just seemed to get destroyed
actually poem by someone you're with
might I don't know if you see that
treble thought battery we might go over
that game later and another sign that
was that was a bit unfortunate yeah he
didn't seem to have dynamism I thought
it a lot it seems to be about dynamism
doesn't it in these games who has the
dynamism often seems to to win the
pressure the dynamic play yeah sure why
didn't have much fun with this extra
exchanges yeah look at all the place yes
okay so so what let's let's wrap this up
here played King to a queen to f4 hmm
yeah and this is just just good move was
frightening there's a friend if he wants
a noisy one yeah just got 91 90 for a
thread also and also rocked the aid to
d2 or rock d8 anywhere on the default
yeah so um very uh yeah very nice
already yeah so one chose Queen h2 which
I wasn't expecting at all but Queen h2
okay so he's offering a free here I mean
it's it's already dead last year but I'm
just assemble line well what I was
really looking at was this move also
rocked the aid and then in luke t 1 I
thought this was was also making some
sense for what but you get this kind of
line he know you need to step up
otherwise you get let's say this year
just already completely oh you win the
rook yeah
yeah all agree on its please check Oh
fruit so haha Sara you cannot so in
queens or whatever it wins everything
winds it's like we're kicking a football
here in this game in the variations
where the footballs like the king he
hates her out drilled all around the
book yeah as I said it like us as on the
fun and now we can even just take him oh
yeah I'm being sent down there there's
nothing I mean you have you have to two
extra pawns and this terrible King so
you know I test it doesn't have have
much here hmm there's a Jew she's Queen
D for being threatened here isn't there
for my yeah he got then you've got the
past over here if you want it it's over
black ass got just two much here yeah
the night is still so much stronger than
the rope here yeah I mean it does help
it's already beyond beyond saving he
went Queen h2 here yeah and yeah just
just grabbed here to get access to the
e4 square knocking out that porn so we
can carry on with checks and then
threatened things like Queen j1 if ya
careful exactly but now the rook can
make an entrance as well we rock the aim
10 3 yeah Robbie pledge night ready to
rock the aid also wins mmm maybe maybe
quicker i don't know i mean it's rock
yet also wins you know later too but
this is also quite nice Queen f3
threatened and yeah I checked with an
engineer I think we're approaching a
mate in 9 by force now yeah the end the
ending of the end position here this sir
check I think this is a force mates in 9
in this position Queen are free yeah
this is Major yeah but ok you can also
win when all kinds of material year so
so I think he resigned after Queen every
check right swish swish one show that
that mating force Martin line from
memory and yeah kingi one and arms onic
here
not quite sure I think okay its one yeah
that looks good for root the eight yeah
because we've got work woven amazingly
yeah even allowing the check is part of
it just because it's only a temporary
inconvenience yeah and now you've got
rocked the aid and then yeah all hell
breaks loose so yeah huge huge friend
and now I mean this one oops not this
one okay 62 f rope g6 on all right
that's an interesting result yeah
considering the circumstances yeah I
know I know you can check I mean no I
can can look at Queen already if you
want yeah but I mean check the chosen
the maid actually check check oh yes
beautiful but yes this is what I had on
board earlier with my funny stuff so
yeah this is the maid wit sure didn't
appear on the board there's so much
entertainment value having a king to
kick kick around it we didn't have this
insatiable champ [ __ ] match we went over
the way these are really fun games yeah
this is fun but I mean no no none of
both participants and the world
championship would be playing this kind
of stuff as white I mean this is really
i'm a bit of a mystery I'm very very
interested to hear what is motivation in
in a lower on this kind of position I
mean not this kind of I mean haha yeah I
met I really I really had a loss I mean
I mean especially Aronian his God shots
just ER he's got such a fine fine
feeling for for his piece activity and
all kinds of it's got on very harmonious
interesting piece play in this game just
kind of position that positional
sacrifice game classic against them that
Netherlands and got a grandmaster it was
a fantastic gear against wasn't yeah
it'll get through yeah yeah pretty
brilliant game with the positional
exchange psyche and here is on the
receiving end of the traditional
exchange tag so why is it positional
exchange sack
places are so dangerous and often in my
early time on YouTube with the
five-minute a lot of people didn't
believe them that I was playing them so
routinely but you get a lot of fun from
sacrificing the exchange in chess yeah
of course I mean it's a sovereign and
it's em I'm sort of falling forward hear
it um I mean the exchange is very
relative value because the rook the rook
some are pieces that are really they
need to certain pro kinds of positions
to really really function properly and
if you look at this game yet move 15
yeah i mean black's pieces look at
black's pieces you've got night on oops
somehow i cannot really mark here not
sure why maybe i need to to go I need to
do this this way okay if you look look
at blacks piece I mean old legs pieces
are sort of on on their best squares and
there they can also easily improve here
I mean the night might jump here this
night can go here this Bishop on b7 is
already yeah its best possible diagonal
this Bishop is controlling squares I
mean these pieces control lots of
squares yeah and they're very very
actively also they also near White's
King I mean 94 night to be 30 okay so
that this rook here doesn't control any
square I mean it cannot go anywhere in
this rope is doing nothing so the
exchange is it's very it's very
difficult to activate those looks I mean
um I don't know I'm not sure if I'm
getting the right words here in English
so in German I always say well white
it's hard to see how white would get
into some sort of realization face here
in the game where he realized just
realize this is extra material like a
slow position where you slowly improve
and you can do all this little kinds of
moves that improve your position
and you win the end game I mean it's
hard to imagine how wide should manage
this he would need I know maybe like
seven or eight moves in a row you tidy
up his position so much that he could
actually think of winning an end game I
mean it's so far away yeah and even I
mean black doesn't have a porn here but
very often those exchange sacrifices
involved that you get some porn like the
typical one in Sicilian on c3 or in the
French where you take on f3 you open you
often get a pawn even a sense the porn
and I mean this is not even from a
material point of view such a huge deal
i mean if you if you do this kind of
kindergarten like counting system like a
bishop is three and a half point united
three points or whatever and rook is
five points let's say a bishop and upon
is it's already quite equal to a look in
this kind of system you know so you can
very often sec those kind of exchanges
and I mean this kind of positions are
also very interesting to play so if you
get the chance to sacrifice in exchange
for for born a nice position then you
should by all means go for it i think
mean it's just interesting although
words often I just just create another
material in hands which is often very
interesting also as sacrificing your
queen for for a rook a minor piece and
upon I really get this quite a lot of my
games and it's very often worth doing if
these pieces are playing together yeah
because I think you can look at it in
terms of career prospects of pieces like
what is the career prospect of this rook
only if maybe H for next year you can
imagine the rook having an open road but
these pieces that have got career
prospects because of the king safety to
blast open the king so they're going to
get even better smashing the center as
well yeah i mean its feisty on each side
idea but we saw that black can even just
play g4 and through okay looking as
stupid as ever yeah and this is just a
problem I mean white would need an
10 or 15 perfect moves in a row to to
get his penis in playing in in a way
maybe you should get rid of other all
the Christmas tree stuff here oh um I
did it's just hard to see how he would
he would do that and like just uh I mean
this place actively in the center and
opens up the position yeah I mean I
prepared this position like I'm not
quite sure it it's a couple of years ago
I don't know seven eight years or so and
back then I didn't didn't analyze it you
know it's like I mean I just I know back
then when I when I and I've know when so
i was so far in this position I just
thought okay I mean this position I just
play I don't need analyze it is black
hmm oh and i was i was absolutely is
this of the board today my xeno anything
what what is he doing silly i can get
like this and that going you end up
losing you gave white dynamism did you
did you end up losing or drawing yeah i
lost I lost very quickly I lost very
quickly he played on he played as I
mentioned before you and us in the ocean
so it's not so it's also interesting but
you get you gave white the pressure
rather than you having all the pressure
unfortunate yeah yeah and I sudden I
completely misjudged her position but am
I don't remember exactly even know I
played this for the what I mean I was
just completely completely destroyed
various porn chains importance have this
pawn maintained on c4 often yeah
brilliant usage of it with that night
that yellow Knight maneuver I think this
also is also something I learned from
that game that I lost it it's very very
achievable to Black's strategy here to
maybe maintain this poem on because it
also helps in this mission yeah you know
and in the game that that I had I mean
it was something like this and I mean
what makes extra porn is just nothing
and white could just develop and you
know it was terrible you give away from
roads for the rooks the rooks are
brilliant career prospects on the on the
end
Foles absolutely bishops got career
prospects as well and on the weaknesses
should we do an overview and summary of
this game just quickly yeah sure okay so
a sloth defense which is full of
surprises still we thought the slav
maybe it was a bit dull from the recent
World Championship match but this shows
some more very super exciting sides of
the Slav personality this when you go
into this h6 and g5 business but here
yeah that Bishop now this this pure
exchange sacrifice this casual kind of
which which supercharges defend cheto
with Bishop d7 and black spaces are all
very nicely centralized now and
improving so this night is destined for
a very aggressive square soon but first
white king is this Lodge which means the
connection between the rooks is in
question the general coordination of
whites pieces are going to be hard to
factoring King safety this beautiful
night maneuver first was the prelude to
an GG for shutting down this rope making
sure no it's not having an easy career
path from the H file just keep that rook
inactive so here King II one setting up
it seems a threat of Bishop f6 and Queen
g4 but that was kind of ignored just
with night be free and now it was shut
down that possibility in any case so
this rook still looking silly this look
rooks looking silly so Bishop e2 and now
this this really wrecking White's pawn
structure to really start to do damage
on the dark squares and this diagonal
now after Bishop c5 is coming up here
this whole diagonal is now shattered
with III as a major target very very
difficult to the fens and this Queens
pretty fantastic on this dog and even if
white did try rotate free but he just
gave up that porn Queens invasion here
setting up all sorts of horrendous
tactics now but this was very nicely
played to gain time in the clock these
repetitious checks because every time
there's a repetition here for
seconds from a shame to come back on the
clock to try and get to that move 40 so
Bishop takes f3 because of this idea of
attacking the rook and then check we see
now check crossing with Queen f4 so
avoiding repetition check now he doesn't
need to you can carry on the exchange
down it's a crushing position there's
all sorts of ideas here and in the game
he check makes use of the night rather
than just wrote dat plays Knight d2
check now this is a forced matin nine
believe it or not and here it's a she
Aronian just resigned here what a
fantastic game that really is
inspirational chess to show but even
against you know one of the strongest
players in the world you can do a very
powerful position exchange sacrifice and
make the opponent's pieces look really
silly for most of the game I'm really
impressed yeah I think it's suddenly a
game that the wide player prefers to
forget quickly I don't know yeah yeah I
mean I mean it's a three it's difficult
to try I really would like to see the
press conference on this game hmm due to
hear what what was white said yeah I
mean I just I said it before thinking he
might have mm maybe it didn't look at at
this said his preparation at all simply
misjudged from ideal move 14 15 or so i
mean i don't know i don't think McShane
is losing rating points anymore to even
though he's got one out free i think
it's about his writing performance yeah
minus one should be should be quite ok
on now the tournament i think it's it's
very interesting up to now we've got
very interesting fighting games also
another great game today was a Grecian
against small savage if it weren't for
this really great upset here aronian
being eaten with wide I think we could
have covered this
easily as well hmm and ya know after
three rounds we've got them to a
tournament leaders thing right job off
with two of two so we consider I attune
to an hour and the other other one is
smaller which was to an hour or so yeah
maybe we should consider more than one
if we get time but we won't promise
anything at this stage I will discuss
that together officer no but this game
of the day ends this is a really cool
game okay hi everyone really enjoyed
that and maybe be more daring to use
positional exchange sacrifices in your
own games okay so thanks Chris thanks
everyone for watching we're going to
upload to our channel soon so king's
cross channel and chess explain channel
comments or questions on on both all
channels on youtube page yeah thanks